progressives over the past like 10 or 20
years have done an absolutely amazing
job at reaching out to minority groups
and disaffected groups and making them
feel like they have a voice they've done
an equally horrible job at kind of
shooting on the prior dominant Group
which is usually like white straight men
I think they've left them feeling like
very disaffected
how effective
if you think consolation is at silencing
people I saw that sneako just got
another strike on his YouTube channel
Lost His Tick Tock account lost his
Twitter and he seems to not really see
it as a concern Andrew Tate says that
he's got even bigger since he left and
then Steve will do it was it the NASDAQ
announcement thing for rumble as well do
you think that it's cope to say you get
bigger when you're canceled or is it
legit uh it's huge cope
um I think canceling is really good at
getting rid of people it's not very good
at getting rid of ideas though so you
can get rid of the man but you're
probably not going to get rid of the
underlying current of thought that
elevated them to the position they were
in before and that's going to still be
there waiting for another person to kind
of like take the reins on it so they set
a type of rhetoric that
um creates an echo that other people can
then fall into kind of yeah or like
um have you ever heard of a concept
called the Overton window yes
um a lot of people don't know this so
they don't seem to understand this the
Overton window is discovered it's not
created politicians are trying to find
where people are and they can move them
a little bit but it's not like
politicians say this is the Overton
window this is how far right and left
they are it's really a big struggle for
politicians trying to figure out like
where are people and then where can I
kind of like slot in myself so that I'm
popular there so like for instance
Donald Trump didn't necessarily
significantly move the Overton window in
in some direction what three dimensions
or two Dimensions or whatever but uh
more he identified whether
coincidentally or not that's a whole
other conversation but he identify
there's a whole group of Voters that
felt a certain way about something and
he was able to tap into that and when
you've got people like Andrew Tate or
sneako that are getting really big it's
because there's a hunger for that type
of thought it's not like these guys are
creating like nobody had known about
this until take a matter it's that there
are certain people that are hungry for
that type of thought so if you ban him
um the Banning is bad for that person
people will cope and say like oh you
can't get canceled like they got even
bigger well then why didn't they just
delete all their socials before like
there's a reason why people want to be
on these platforms but there's still
going to be that underlying current of
thought and somebody's going to come by
that's another red pillar or mgtow or
whatever and take the reins on it I
think yeah I think you're right I think
based on what I've seen when you remove
people from that ecosystem the audience
at best the absolute best that you can
hope for is it stays as big as it is now
but the discovery medium is these
platforms that have millions and
billions of users right if you're off
YouTube there is no more discoverability
for you if you're off Instagram and Tick
Tock how are people going to find you
you saw this with Alex Jones right Alex
Jones had an a country-sized audience he
got removed from social media but you
know that unless he creates some
incredibly smart referral scheme how are
new people going to discover his message
I mean yeah you're exactly right like
it's yeah I it's such an annoying to
argue with people because it's such a
massive cup otherwise and it betrays
everything we know about like how these
platforms work like if I'm a platform
and I'm buying Talent the reason why I'm
buying talent to come to my platforms
because I'm trying to bring their fan
base over you know I want to be on a
platform where people are there not
because Destiny's there but because
they're watching other people if people
are coming to a platform only for me
that means that that platform doesn't
have anything else left like for me to
to grow from you know like so Rumble is
definitely growing a ton off of Andrew
Tate but I don't think Andrew Tate is
going to grow a ton off of Rumble yes
very interesting well there has to be a
critical mass where Rumble could acquire
so much talent that it might actually
start to move the needle for instance
spotify's acquisition of call hadadi and
Rogan
changed what people listened on maybe
there's an argument to be made that
people are going to watch some video
content and there may be a little bit
more platform agnostic but I would argue
that the reason Spotify worked is most
people already had it Spotify was coming
in with a huge amount of existing brand
equity and it's actually a genuinely
better experience for listening to
podcasts on too so it's a superior
product that already had Equity coming
in as opposed to rumble who are kind of
holding on to the coattails of these big
creators that they're bringing over
staple do and sneako tape yeah the books
are still probably being written on how
to do this effectively like nobody
really knows 100 like how do I grow an
alternative platform
um there's a reason why I don't know the
stuff to my head but I'm willing to bet
that like Twitter Facebook these
planners are probably like 15 years old
at this point right
um I know Facebook is at least that old
Twitter is probably I feel like I've
seen tweets from 2008
um so like these are old platforms and
people have tried to start new platforms
buy a bunch of talent and it still kind
of falls through so yeah it's very
difficult to grow a new platform
completely organically unless you're
literally offering like the whole
package like you said it's got to be a
product that's good on its own that is
like why would I use this over something
else it's got to have unique talent
there that you can't find in other
places it's got to have some kind of
discoverability or hook in areas on
other parts of the internet that people
are using like there's a lot that has to
go right and man the barrier to entry
for stuff I got is probably getting
higher and higher and higher every day
like pharmaceutical levels in terms of
how much money you have to spend to get
people over on these platforms yeah yeah
well I mean Tick Tock perfect example
right I thought I thought we'd reached
saturation for the number of different
channels that people would have because
this other stuff I know you hear about
people that use
gab or yikiak you remember Yik Yak do
you ever see that I don't think I did no
so it was location based announcement
kind of like Twitter but it was all
Anonymous so you couldn't see who did it
and it was all location based so you
could basically spread rumors about
people that it was a Gossip Girl but on
a thread and it was completely location
based so you would only see the stuff
that was around you oh I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna remember this but um I I know
what you're talking about kind of there
was another app called like whisper or
something it wasn't called that but it
was similar like basically when you'd
open the app there's like 20 things but
it's all said by people luckily Aaron
you don't know who it is right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah my point being that when
I saw those I was like oh yeah well this
will be a cool thing for maybe a
subculture or maybe it'll try to get off
the ground but probably fail Tick Tock
actually managed to get into the market
and hold on to it because it had a
superior product to everything else that
was online without that and I'm not
convinced that Rumble quite has that yet
yeah yeah and I mean there's going to be
companies that um I'm sure people are
going to be doing case studies on like
how they mess something up because like
um
we're on Skype right now right yes what
a letdown that somehow Zoom was able to
come out of nowhere and become like a
massive company like whoever was the
product manager at Skype dropped the
ball on that harder than almost any
other company in history or what if you
were the person that ran Vine and you're
like okay well obviously short form
content like this doesn't work on the
internet mobile app so it's time to
leave and now like 10 years later you've
got like Tick Tock and it's like oh my
God like is that like this is like a guy
the proverbial like 10 000 Bitcoin
holder on an old hard drive somewhere I
was like what mine was he like messed it
up somehow it's like yeah so you know
I'm sure that like I I bet the ultimate
answer if I was God and I could come
down and figure out everything I bet
that there's like 40 is like all of this
like you've got to have the right Talent
the right allocation of resources the
right product blah blah and I'm willing
to bet like 50 60 can just be like right
place right time like a lot of it might
just be down to luck like a certain deal
getting signed a certain thing going
viral on the internet that slowly starts
to propagate more uses to your platform
Etc like there's there's so many
variables when it comes to internet
stuff I think you're right and yeah
it'll be interesting man it'll be
interesting to see because that like I
said there has to be a um critical mass
let's say that every YouTuber with over
300K Subs moved to rumble exclusively
people would people would start watching
that now yes absolutely YouTube would
other creators would come through and
fill up some of that watch time but the
question about how much do you need in
order to tip the balance we've seen this
with uh some of the guys that have moved
from twitch to YouTube gaming that's a
big sort of competition that's going on
at the moment and twitch keeps on
seeming to shoot itself in the foot in
the face and the knee and yeah
everything else at the moment
yeah um I agree the um
uh I mean take everything I say they're
going to solve it but the one business
model that I want to see try that hasn't
been done yet is I feel like people are
really Keen to buy talent and then they
just do that but they don't engage with
the talent well like I feel like if I
ran another platform I would want to buy
a talent that still Associates with a
lot of people on the other platform one
that's important and the second thing is
I would want to do something with them
that's unique that they didn't do before
so that people be like motivated to go
and watch right uh like if somebody was
gonna buy me a talent for a platform you
could stick me somewhere else on me
stream but like are people going to
watch it like I'm still gonna put up
YouTube videos like are they willing to
care that much but if you were to buy me
his talent and then put me on your
platform and you did like a like a
boxing series I don't think I would ever
do this but if you did something crazy
like that well now it's like okay cool
yeah he's on a new platform which is
kind of annoying but he's doing a new
cool thing I've ever seen Live Events
with a panel yeah an audience or some
[ __ ] yeah it's not enough in this day
and age
um I don't actually know your background
if you're working like the tech world or
whatnot but like if you're in the
entrepreneurial Tech world there's an
ungodly amount of money that flies
around in these rooms like the worst
projects ever get like seven figure
rounds of funding eight figure rounds of
funding so he's like what is happening
here it's not enough just throw money at
something because if that was the
solution like people would have already
discovered these other platforms you
have to engage with it in a more
intelligent way in a more creative way
than just like oh I paid him you know
five million dollars a year why didn't
he you know grow my platform it's like
you know
what are your thoughts on the manosphere
at the moment what do you think it gets
right and wrong
um
I I'll say very carefully because the
manosphere is a very broad sphere and
will incorporate everything from people
thinking that like women are actual
demons that are meant to be like used
and abused and manipulated to further
yourself in life all the way to this
other end where it's like you know women
act a certain way men a certain way it's
good to be aware of this so that you can
make yourself and the people around you
happier more successful so let me caveat
by that
um broadly speaking I I think that
um I think that progressives over the
past like 10 or 20 years have done an
absolutely amazing job at reaching out
to minority groups and disaffected
groups and making them feel like they
have a voice uh we have awesome
representation in media even if some of
it's a little cringe sometimes you know
we're debating things like transports
when 15 or 20 years ago the only trans
person you've ever seen on TV was on
Jerry Springer or Mari we have like uh
you know different races people in
different areas the visibility is
awesome they've done a really good job
at that they've done it equally horrible
job at kind of [ __ ] on the prior
Domino Group which is usually like white
straight men
um and they I think they've left them
feeling like very disaffected it's kind
of sad it seems to be part of like human
nature that to advance one group it
seems like we almost like have to [ __ ]
on another group that's like a required
part of The Human Experience
um but yeah I think you've got kind of
this group of like kind of things like
white go these like white dudes that are
kind of like hanging out and you know
they they have all this white privilege
but they're lonely some of them don't
have very much money
um they're not doing too well in school
and no part of society seems interested
in talking to them anymore I think that
that kind of opened up this opportunity
for initially it was like the Ben
shapiroes or like the Jordan Petersons
especially or the Joe Rogan's kind of
talk these people and now that whole
section has kind of exploded out into
like the manosphere where you've got all
these people willing to kind of give
advice or talk to these basically these
kind of like disaffective only white
dudes that feel like no or not even just
white dudes but disaffected only men
that feel like um Society kind of
doesn't want to talk to them anymore
because they're toxic or they're
horrible or they're abusers or they're
rapists or you know it's an interesting
blend of cultural and structural
problems of this guy in the show called
Richard Reeves he's written a book
called of boys and men and it looks at
all of the conversations that you will
be familiar with about evolutionary
psychology and around the so the
cultural interpretation of what it means
to be a man today and how that plays out
in in the broader culture but he came at
it from a completely structural
perspective and he was saying things
like
in order for a male to have the same
level of impulse control as a 10 year
old girl
he needs to be 24.
as behavioral genetic studies Catherine
page Harden who's out here in Austin and
is also from the left which is
interesting as somebody that does
behavioral genetics because that's
typically not uh she released this study
looking at impulse control impulse
control of a 10 year old girl is the
same as a 24 year old man it's wild my
point being that there are structural
issues that need to be looked at but yes
as long as you are unable to have a
conversation like this publicly without
being there being an assumption that
it's a zero-sum game and games for one
are the loss of the other uh another
thing to consider I've been talking
about this a lot as well
intra-sexual competition is
significantly more prevalent than
intersexual competition almost all
competition is within your own sex not
between the Sexes men compete with men
and women compete with women and yet
we've somehow been convinced that we are
each other's enemies rather than
compatriots
yeah for sure there's a lot of weird
stuff that goes on with the way that
everything is framed these days
um the son that you said that the
problem is that like
there you can go so deep on so many of
these conversations but we can't even
get any of these conversations off the
ground like even starting some of these
conversations basically makes you like
Public Enemy Number One and then you're
just kind of like completely shot down
um so it seems like over the past five
or ten years we've made like zero
progress on any of these things and
there is kind of like a there's kind of
like an Orthodoxy of thought right now
for certain things I had a school
administrator email me one time because
I'd been digging into like School
related stuff and how it seemed like it
was kind of moving pretty far in One
Direction and um I don't know if you're
familiar with this but right now in the
United States women
um and Men there's like a 60 40 divide
in schools right now where Women are 60
of the new graduates and men are 40
That's unbelievably tipped on the other
side of where it was before and then um
you mentioned structural problems
something interesting too is I think
during the covid-19 period
um I think men were more likely to have
to drop out of school to work to support
their families than women were so it
like grew the Divide even more
um but the school administrator emailed
me and he's like the idea that you could
even Broach that topic breach that topic
and have that conversation like maybe we
need like affirmative action for men in
schools or maybe we need to start
looking at that that's like an
inconceivable conversation you can never
even begin to have it so yeah we're
definitely in an awkward point right now
where there's a lot of important
conversations that need to be had but
the mainstream and progressives won't
have it so then as a result only people
on the very far right will have it and
I'll agree with the left that like a lot
of the conversations happening on the
far right are really dog [ __ ] but they
have nobody to blame but themselves
because they're not willing to engage in
this conversation so what do you say
yeah exactly yeah and I always say that
that's a good question when it comes to
like Jordan Peterson or Joe Rogan people
like these are horrible male role models
it's like I kind of agree to some extent
what's your alternative
you have nothing you have nobody you
don't even want to talk to these people
because you think that um like you think
that men are fine and they don't need
any help for anything and they've been
the patriarchy and blah blah blah blah
and it's like damn I remember learning
about the patriarchy like five or ten
years ago and back then when we talked
about the patriarchy we talked about how
the patriarch it was oppressive to men
and to women why does it only seem to
negatively affect women now right like I
don't understand how uh it feels like
all the old stuff we talked about
doesn't matter anymore and now it's just
this hyper fixation on moving
um I hate using words like woke but like
moving in that direction as much as
possible and then yeah it's not
surprising that you've got only far
right figures or right leaning figures
at least willing to talk to the the
disaffected male group that's a good way
to frame it that I hadn't thought about
before the fact that by not bothering to
engage with this you open up the floor
inevitably for only one side to dominate
I don't think that that's particularly
good in any situation it should you
should have multiple inputs but if you
don't then you're going to have it
completely besieged by one so on the
point of the Dropout of men this is from
my newsletter from last week uh in the
span of just a few decades girls and
women have not only caught up with boys
and men in the classroom they've blown
right past them half a century ago the
landmark Title IX law was passed to
promote gender equality in higher
education at the time there was a gap of
13 percentage points in the proportion
of bachelor's degrees going to men
compared with women today the gender gap
is a little wider 15 percentage points
as of 2019 but the other way around for
every three female college students that
are only about two men the trend
worsened during the pandemic college
enrollment as a whole declined in 2020
but that decline was seven times greater
for male than for female students
[ __ ] wild in some ways that's awesome
like we got more women in school we got
them educated that's so cool it wasn't
like a a lot of people were like
biologically like women are stupid they
can't do blah blah and there was a lot
of research and I was like no that's not
true women are actually in some ways
better at school than men because of the
temperament differences between men and
women and who's able to sit in a
classroom and focus whatever which is
cool but we have to be able to maintain
like Focus like the focus wasn't on
making women dominate men it was making
sure that we had some parity in society
that we were able to kind of like that
both sides have the opportunity to
explore expand and succeed in school as
much as possible and if it feels like
one group is being left behind even if
that group is somebody that previously
was like a major power holder we should
be able to have the conversation like
okay well what can we do to like bring
men back into the classroom but man even
just saying those words it's like I can
already imagine like people freaking out
like what do you mean men men make up 85
percent of CEOs and men are earning out
earning women still you know 92 to 100
blah blah blah and I was like okay well
you know [ __ ] I guess you know if we're
if we're gonna go uh if we're gonna go
to the extremes and then that's where
you're going to draw your data from and
I guess we just can't further the
conversation at all you know there's an
argument to be made that it's all well
and good talking about how many CEOs and
men but this doesn't really help the
group of poverty-stricken drug adult
incarcerated suicidal men at the bottom
you get men at both ends of the scale I
also agree I've come to believe that
women do better than females do better
than males school they just
categorically they do better than males
in school and the only reason that we
didn't see this is because females had
the break spot on them and now that
we've released the brakes I I don't
think that it's possible now you could
say well there should be different types
of learning there should be different
types of schooling maybe even gendered
schooling that actually helps uh boys to
what get more Play Time be outside more
uh certainly most male School teachers
here's a stat that I learned uh there
are
four times as many female fighter pilots
in the U.S Air Force as there are male
kindergarten teachers in the USA
two percent of kindergarten teachers in
the USA are male and seven percent of
fighter pilots in the US Air Force are
female now they're both of those may be
underrepresented maybe there maybe
should be more female fighter pilots but
to say that it's nice wait hold on that
they're really only two percent of
teachers are male is that true
kindergarten teachers yes kindergarten
okay geez that's crazy I went to um this
is weird but I I grew up very Catholic I
went to a Jesuit High School so the
majority of my teachers were at male but
that was high school too but um damn
that's a crazy stat yeah two percent of
yeah and if you have a boy and a girl
that goes into the head teacher's office
for the same offense indiscretion
whatever you want to say the boy is
two to four times as likely to be
expelled as a girl uh I like the prison
system kind of right
men are more likely to receive given the
same background or whatever are more
likely to get harsher punishments from
judges than women typically are yeah
but um digging into the manosphere a
little bit more do you think that the
red pill movement is a net good for the
world
man I don't really know it's hard to say
like
if I get my hands to some of these guys
we start talking their messages are
usually pretty good but then when I'm
not there and I listen to talk I kind of
wonder sometimes it's hard because like
sometimes I feel like when somebody's
there to hold them a little bit more
accountable and I'll say the same for me
too like this is why I learned this uh a
random Side Story there's a horrible
geeky game have you ever heard of a game
called Eve online yeah it's the one
where you make massive sponsorships and
drive around and stuff um I learned a
lot about like leadership structures and
managing people whatever through that
game which is really funny but something
that I learned was that any time there
was an argument for a particular idea it
is essential to have a person on each
side of that argument because you always
need to be holding yourself accountable
and if you've got everybody on one side
you can run off in a way we've got a lot
of blind spots you can start to miss
everything where I'm like oh well we
should have thought of this we should
have that so anytime even if I like as a
leader of my little game Corporation
even if I felt strong I'd be like we
should do this thing I would always make
sure that there was another guy pointed
to like tell me like this is why we
shouldn't do it and even if I decided to
at least I knew like well these are the
drawbacks to why we um shouldn't do this
particular thing
I feel like with um with a lot of online
political talk with a lot of the
manuscript guys or with me it's good to
have two voices there or like a
moderating voice you don't have to agree
with everything I say but I don't know
how much you've listened to some of
these conversations so like when we
start getting into like terms or
vernacular like the [ __ ] Carousel or the
thousand yard or the Thousand Cox there
like weird [ __ ] like this what's the
Thousand characters for women that have
too much sex or like the [ __ ] carousell
as women will [ __ ] throughout their 20s
and then they settle down with some poor
schmuck in their 30s after they've
[ __ ] their way through 50 million
people live yeah like we decided to get
seriously I feel you need somebody to
ground you out a little bit more because
the conversations start to get insanely
one-sided and you're not accurately
representing like what's truly going on
in a lot of these um interactions so
yeah so it's hard to say like when I'm
talking to a lot of the red pill guys if
I get on their shows and I talk their
messages are in my opinion usually
resoundingly positive they're talking
about things like self-improvement
you're talking about things like wealth
and girls should be a byproduct of the
improvements that you make in your life
they're not the goal it's just something
that will occur if you make yourself
successful
um you know it's usually overwhelmingly
positive messages that usually tie into
what I would consider to be the positive
aspects of masculinity but it feels like
sometimes if I'm not there or if I'm
listening in the background and there's
other stuff going on it starts to get
like very toxic like very quickly
um what do you mean by toxic
um like the the idea that like um
women are like different types of women
are there to be churned and burned that
women are like kind of like very
subservient to men and very like
inferior in a lot of different ways that
um that the value of women is tied in
almost completely to like the amount of
sex they can give you or how they look
and that like um women that pursue
things like going to college or like
furthering themselves or like
masculinizing themselves in a really
negative way
um yeah I think these kinds of ideas get
just the view of women in general if it
feels and I understand to some extent
sex is kind of like a competition in a
way but when you start to view all of
life that way kind of like what you said
in the beginning where it's like men
versus women um like I think that you
should probably view women as like your
partners through life and not like these
adversaries you're trying to trick into
[ __ ] you constantly it'll probably
give you a better Outlook I think dude
you've nailed it it's the adversarial
relationship I think and this is
zero-sum game the the
presumption seems to be if a man sleeps
with you it is your loss and his gain I
mean it's just let's just use that as a
starting point that doesn't seem to me
I've met about a million people in my
life and about half of half of them were
women right on the front door of
nightclubs working so I've seen people
at their most unencumbered between the
hours of 10 pm and three in the morning
for the most part they get on absolutely
fine I don't think that they're trying
to [ __ ] each other over my experience of
human nature is that almost everybody is
pretty kind and gentle and yeah there's
some [ __ ] out there but for the most
part everybody's pretty sweet yeah one
thing that's interesting you mentioned
about the fact that a lot of the sort of
red pill advice focuses on
self-improvement it always seems to have
an undertone or an undercurrent of that
self-improvement even if it's just for
you
still being in service of getting girls
eventually that the best way to get a
girl is to focus on yourself this focus
on yourself is just a smoke screen to
hide the real goal of still being
reliant on validation from girls yeah
that it's it's very funny too because
the more toxic you get into that sphere
nothing is more funny to me than like a
group of guys that are talking about how
[ __ ] worthless women are and they're
these [ __ ] and Horrors blah blah blah
but like at the end of the day like how
do they signal that they're like top
[ __ ] it's because they've got like
really hot girls next to them like
nothing is more funny to me than seeing
that like you need that validation so
much that women are like at one end
they're like these incredibly
adversarial things to be conquered but
then in the other end they give you more
about like a dude walking in with like a
twenty thousand dollar watch and like a
fifty thousand dollar suit doesn't look
as good as the guy walking with the four
hot girls because if he's got four
different hot women that are validated
that guy must be the coolest dude in the
world selection yeah yeah exactly so
it's like it's a very interesting world
to see the that sometimes the more I
remember listening to this one this is
really famous old like inside speech
that this guy spends like all those
times like these slots are coming into
our world now and blah blah blah blah
blah and then like in the next part of
the speech he's like I'm gonna show you
guys how to get two or three of these
girls at the same [ __ ] time and it
was so funny that while he's
simultaneously talking about how [ __ ]
horrible and slutty's women are he's
going to show you how cool You Are by
getting you a lot of these girls because
that's ultimately where the validation
comes from and that's very funny to me
what sort of guys do you think
or what sort of girls do you think that
the guys who follow red pill will be
getting because it seems to me that
there is a selection bias for the kind
of interactions that a lot of the guys
that followed that philosophy to the
absolute T will get and that will Jade
and color their view of women overall
yeah
um yeah I definitely think that you can
shop for certain types of women that
will probably reinforce certain types of
beliefs this is always one of the big
criticisms I have when I'm on some of
these shows is that like um like it
feels like they they get themselves
stuck into these like self-perpetuating
Cycles where if you're only valuing
women for like let's say you come in
with the mindset like okay if a woman's
got a college degree she's earning a lot
of money she's masculinized okay [ __ ]
her
um and then if a woman's not like
looking her best and taking care of
herself or blah blah blah like she's not
being feminine enough so [ __ ] them so
like who are you left with you've got
like girls that like never went to
school girls that are focused on their
looks all the time girls that are like
relatively shallow like when you're in
this group of people and now on this
group of people you're like well look at
how women act all they're trying to do
is like you know [ __ ] up in terms of
like [ __ ] upward socially Mobility
they're trying to find like really
wealthy men like they don't give up
they're really shallow like they don't
know like any of the [ __ ] about like
what how many countries are on the
planet blah blah blah yeah you end up in
this cycle like of course that's the
type of women that you're like hitting
over and over again you're hitting on
because that's like the the message that
you're sending out to the world like
this is the only type of woman that
you're even looking at like everybody
else is invisible to you
um so yeah I definitely think a lot of
these worlds get into these
self-reinforcing Cycles where they
filter out everybody that doesn't agree
with how they view the world old and
then if you filter out enough then
obviously every single thing you find is
going to reinforce your point of view
do you think that the red pill guys are
kind of but some of them could if they
took this to the nth degree kind of
Poison the Well for other men because as
you sleep around more you create the
alpha widows that other men are taught
to avoid so there is a finite pool of
women and if you leave a bunch of broken
ones in your wake because that's part of
the philosophy that you follow like it
seems to me the fundamental issue that I
have with the current iteration of men's
advice from this side of the internet is
that it helps
individual men at the expense of pretty
much everybody else
yeah I mean like there's I mean we could
do like a seven hour show on the
hilarious contradictions of like all of
that
um two really funny ones are um oh man
you just you just brought up the um like
the the the the alpha male right the the
titular widow or yeah well like the
alpha male creates Alpha widows right
yes or yeah like because the point is
you're supposed to have as many girls as
possible like these guys will talk about
like have you heard of the concept of
like this one-sided open relationship
a little bit it's like more and more
popular that I see popping up in these
spheres where they're like oh yeah like
a normal a good relationship is where
the man is open to [ __ ] as many women as
he wants but the woman is close and she
can't [ __ ] either man that's like
becoming more it feels like the norm in
these circles and I'm like I mean how
many men could do this before all those
other women now are like ruined like
isn't that kind of a bad cycle to be in
you're talking about like one percent of
the men [ __ ] it up and it's funny
because these guys will talk about like
you I'm sure you've heard have you heard
the term hypergamy yes of course like
aren't you aren't you by virtue of
telling people to do that like
furthering like the amount of hypergamy
in society aren't you like ruining
everything by doing this
um there's there's that that you're like
creating a worse World by the way that
you live if you really think that's a
bad World which they seem to think there
was a second argument that I got into
once in the show I was on the fresh
unfit show and it was really funny I
think everybody agrees that like you
have to stay away from single moms it's
the worst thing ever
um what did um [ __ ] I already had this
term for him
I don't know it's like something like
use them and lose him or something he
had like a thing for him I was like oh
my one-time use only or for fun use only
whatever it's like Jesus but then later
on in the show and we all talked about
how like if you're a single dad usually
you're in a better position a day than
like a sickle mom et cetera et cetera we
like everybody agreed on this ubiquitous
on the panel and even I agree that to
something simple moments you have a
harder time but it was really funny
because on the later part of the show we
got into something about like the
unfairness that men face in like the
court systems and somehow like alimony
and single moms came up again but now
these guys talking about like single
moms are in the best spot in the world
because every woman that divorces
apparently gets like a five figure a
month paycheck from their husband and
they get tons of they get all this
alimony all this child support they take
across their car and then my question's
like well hold on I thought you said the
single moms were [ __ ] now you're
making it sound like single moms are the
best people in the world today like why
would I want to date a single dad who's
a loser and lost all of his money when I
could go up to a single mom whose
ex-boyfriend is paying for all of her
[ __ ] that sounds like the best range and
they had a really hard time trying to
parse out like bringing these two
different Like Trains of thought into
one another because like well [ __ ] well
our single mom's in a really bad spot or
they also are they are they actually the
best people in the world they're like
yeah I think if you dig in really hard
on the manuscript stuff you start to run
into like a lot of very strange
contradictions to where either like
different ideas when they're brought
together are incongruent or you're like
actively furthering and creating a worse
World by the advice you're giving to
people that's why I started with the
question do you think that it's a net
positive or negative for the world I I
it's it's an interesting one man I've
slowly started to change my opinion on a
number of the creators like fresh and
fits one of them as I've taken more of
the good kernels out of it I'm like okay
like there's some there's some really
good stuff in here
it's framed and packaged so often in in
things that it's difficult to Discount
alongside that though so I've been
thinking for a long time about the idea
of a third wave manosphere right yeah so
I think purple pill I think that
first wave manosphere was pickup
Artistry it was Neil Strauss it was the
game it was mystery it was negging and
like neuro-linguistic programming and
canned openers and all that stuff and
then me too happened that was not going
to survive me too maybe it wouldn't have
survived in any case but me too sort of
hurried the onset of that so you needed
to sanitize the advice that was being
given to men especially around dating it
couldn't be as transactional it couldn't
be as aggressive uh and then out the
other side of that now you have instead
of it being pick up and game it's high
value man it's Alpha Beta it's uh
talking about evolutionary psychology
more so it's discussing markets sexual
market value and stuff like that I still
think that the fundamental issue that it
has is that it sees men and women as
adversaries I think that you need to
have a version of this where you can
have collaboration where you can
pedestalize men as fathers where you can
pedestalize women as mothers like
one of the biggest contradictions that
you see is monogamy is something which
is good at least in society overall
because it is a sexual redistribution
strategy that helps men at the bottom to
get partners it allows more societal
stability it encourages conservative and
Traditional Values amongst women which
is something which also seems to be
upheld but in the same sentence you're
looking to run through as many women as
you can that doesn't seem to really
marry those two things together and
again the man's win is the woman's loss
and to me that doesn't seem like a very
collaborative way not a positive some
way abundant way to frame this so I'm
just thinking about what a third wave
manosphere would look like how would you
be able to advise men and have this I
understand that there's a sexiness to
certainty that comes with a lot of the
messaging okay so what would a third
wave manosphere look like yeah I guess
it's like I wish that people I I think
that and this is what I always thought
the red pill guys a lot of the
descriptions they make a lot of the
observations they make about how things
work is usually pretty true and I think
that's how people hook it initially
because they are describing real things
sometimes in stark contrast to what like
the left is going to say like the left
will say things like oh like you know no
matter how a woman looks um you know we
should still love her or like oh like no
matter how much money a man earns like
we all love men no matter what the same
way or like that's not important like
that's shallow but like if you go into
the real world obviously people are
making decisions relating to stuff like
this all the time so you immediately
discount anything they're going to say
if you're gonna lie to me you're gonna
blow smoke on my ass I'm like I know you
immediately and then you go to the red
pill guys and they're like well you know
money is pretty important to women and
the security you can provide and you
know for men like they do like younger
pretty ones like okay cool that's cool
and then you get into their you know
kind of world and then they're telling
you yeah women like security
um because they're backstabbing
conniving [ __ ] [ __ ] that are only
looking to take care of their progeny
and their offspring and they'll leave
you in a second if they find a more
successful man so you need to [ __ ] her
and make sure that she stays loyal and
it's like okay holy [ __ ] Jesus
um the descriptions will be accurate but
then like the analysis past the
description is good so negative and it's
like Jesus like it would be nice if you
could bundle up like you you have your
observations but then you kind of find
ways to to make these more
understandable so like uh like here's
something that I consider right people
will say things like women are drawn
towards success because they like money
and they like security and they want to
provide for their children and that's
probably partially true I'm sure there's
like some extent of that is true but I'm
also sure that the types of people that
become successful are also probably
types of people that are pretty
attractive if you've made it really far
in some business or some industry you
probably have a lot of traits that
aren't just good for that industry
they're probably good for people too
right like I hope I do decently as a
stream running YouTuber I hope that I
also can do decently in conversations I
can like be pretty entertaining in real
life I can have you know like good
experiences with people and there's
going to be like a lot of crossover
between like what makes a person really
successful versus what also makes a
person like a cooler fun or awesome
person to hang around um and I think
that like trying to view things more
realistically through that lens rather
than this like hyper bastardized hyper
obsessive need to use like Evo psych to
explain every facet of human interaction
um I I just I feel like the former is so
much better than the latter is healthier
and more like you said more
collaborative maybe it puts us all kind
of on this path where it's like okay how
can we improve all of ourselves rather
than where it feels like we're in
Survivor trying to [ __ ] over the other
parties as much as possible while still
making out as well as we can an
interesting question that I would ask
any of the guys in the red pill world is
do you think that you need to educate
women about how to be better
collaborative partners with men on
average as well as men and it seems to
me that you do it seems to me that books
like mate by Toca Max and Jeffrey Miller
if you've been familiar with that so
they basically did this about 10 years
ago and they Jeffrey Miller is one of
the fathers of evolutionary psychology
he's done many of the seminal studies
that people refer to when they're
talking about this dating and gender
Dynamics in The Mating system
they wrote a book this book would be
amazing for every woman to read as well
all women should read that book
if you want to make the dating Market a
better place for everybody overall you
need to bring women along too yeah and
it's a very specific type of woman that
is going to sit down I mean Kevin
Samuels you know as an example it's a
very specific type of woman that would
have taken that rhetoric that he was
putting forward and go yeah actually
that's that's what that's what I want to
hear that's not to say that he didn't
have an impact on some women that
listened but it's a quite an extreme way
to go about it that I can imagine will
raise more hackles than it convinces
people gently yeah I definitely agree
kind of on that same kind of thought and
I don't know I might just miss it are
there any red pill people that talk
about relationships at all because I
feel like they only talk about like
getting the girl initially I don't know
if I've ever heard a Red Bull person
talk about like these are the things you
need to do to maintain healthy strong
relationships have you seen there's a
subreddit called married red pill no I
haven't seen it at all no married red
pill is applying Eve psych red pill
Dynamics to sustaining a long-term
relation [ __ ] so yeah kind of the only
the only creator that I can think of is
Hamza he's the only guy that I can think
of that fits into that particular Niche
he's got a girlfriend at the moment he
uploaded he uploaded a video with him
and his girl walking down the street to
just being happy or something the other
day and some guy decided to comment on
YouTube saying something like um imagine
putting in all of this effort for an
absolute [ __ ] pig something like that
because he didn't like I'm like yo
that's the area of the internet that uh
I really really don't want to be
associated with but you're right I most
guys are going to end up in a long-term
committed relationship
surely optimizing for what most guys are
going to get is a good way to educate
them and starting where they are as well
I think you talk about kind of the
selection effect of having an open
relationship that it's only for a very
specific type of person the very
specific mental makeup and maybe not
everybody can deal with that and even if
you can maybe you can't find a partner
or partners that are prepared to deal
with that as well
well do we not need to try and get
people to the stage uh meet them where
they're at and slowly try and improve
people from there and yeah the main the
main issue is this zerosome mentality
it's the fact that a man's gain is a
woman's loss
and I wonder what a more holistic
version of it would look like yeah yeah
I definitely agree the the adversarial
part the the winning and losing is is a
really bad way to look at things and
leads to a ton of negative outcomes yeah
consider as well that men have got a
huge loneliness problem at the moment so
in the UK two out of five men have no
friends at all and I worry that
some of the rhetoric sees all men as
either threats or enemies rather than
friends or companions like you need to
be able to see other men not just the
ones that can help you further your body
count this week or bank balance next
month as people that you can collaborate
with
I that's a yeah that's another thing too
that I talk about a lot or that I've
talked about a lot that men we we kind
of suck at friendships compared to women
I think that women are uh
I want to say a lot today I saw I think
it was like of all the men that are
single I think it's like 24 of them are
okay with being single forever but I
think for women that number is like 37
or 38 it's like almost uh like 15 points
higher and um or or maybe it was like 10
or 15 points wouldn't have guessed that
um I think that the one of the reasons I
think is because if you look at the way
that men communicate with each other
versus women communicate with each other
women friendships are very emotionally
satisfying there is a lot of
gratification there between opening up
and sharing close and intimate details
with each other and for male friendships
we don't do that much at all and it
seems like for men kind of the only
place you ever really get that if you're
comfortable with it is from a woman is
through like a relationship like with a
woman
um so I think that like having a bunch
of men that have and I don't know if
you've experienced this like I've had
like groups of friends where like we're
all guys we talked to each other we're
actually like one dude like destroys
life and we're just going like good luck
man like you know it's on you like I
hope you can pick it up but you don't
really want to like pull and say like
hey we need to have like a deep talk
about you making some really bad
decisions whatever
um whereas for like women friendships
like they hold each other like
emotionally accountable a lot more or I
know there's been I'm guaranteeing like
every single stand-up comedian has had
like this same skit where he's like you
know a guy gets home and he talks to the
other guy he's like what'd you do it's
like went to work anything fun nope like
what'd you do after got a drink like
okay and then like for women then when
they talked I was like oh I went to work
and I saw Sarah and we tried this and
she told me about this like the
communication is way more more better
more better
um but yeah I think that that fleshing
out male friendships is probably a good
thing too we don't talk about that
either I think well it's seen as
something that men should innately know
about I think you should just be able to
find friends as an adult but I had a
this guy called Max Dickens on the show
and he told me this really sort of
moving story he was getting to the stage
where he was about to engage get married
to his partner so he proposes to her and
then after he's got engaged he's going
to get his suit fitted his wedding suit
and he was with a female friend that
he's known for ages his female friend
turned to him and said uh so who's going
to be your best man and no one came to
mind and he said I I I must just be
being a little bit confused or something
it'll just give me give me a few minutes
and I'll be able to work it out and he
looked at his list of male friends and
they were all people that he worked with
but didn't really know that well that he
would feel a little bit strange if he
asked them to be his best man yeah and
he realized holy [ __ ] where have all of
my male friends gone and this is
something that's very common that once
men get into relationships they absorb
the friend group of the female and that
becomes their new Social Circle and that
first off closes off the potential size
of the Social Circle because they can't
ever go and find new people to bring
into their wife's friends group and also
if they ever lose the wife the
Friendship group goes away as well yeah
so it makes for a a very lonely
existence and I think that yeah working
out how men can be more collaborative in
that way too is is pretty pretty
important do you ever talk about work
from home no not much
I feel like a lot of people have
championed it and they like it but I'm
worried that like work from home is
going to be like that final tether to
reality that is going to snap and a lot
of people are just man dude over the
coronavirus pandemic when a lot of
people are doing for work from home and
they still do it I think there's a lot
of guys that like literally for eight
months they never left their [ __ ]
house
um and for a lot of people like our work
environments are already male dominated
so it's hard well like if you're a man
you work like an attacker like STEM
related stuff it's like gonna be two
women to like every 100 men
um but even for finding like male guy
friends or just seeing people every day
I get really scared when people are
doing the work from home thing more and
more and more and it's like if you are a
social person that's good because you're
still going out and doing things but if
you're not man you're like losing the
last bit of human interaction except
maybe saying hi to like your doordash
delivery person that you're ever gonna
get absolutely man yeah that's a really
good point I I think that there was some
work done in this by Scott Galloway uh
dude from NYU who I had on yesterday and
he was talking about how the work from a
home phenomenon had caused increases in
social anxiety obviously it increases in
screen time use all of this stuff that
ever everybody independently says it's a
bad idea
what happens I think is we confuse a
comfortable or convenient activity for a
worthwhile or enjoyable one like just
because you don't need to do the commute
to work just because you get to wear a
shirt up top but shorts or boxes down
below doesn't necessarily mean that this
is good for you it doesn't necessarily
mean that you should lean into working
from home and perhaps overall even
though it might be more inconvenient and
more difficult it might actually be
better to make that trip into the office
something that I think we're going to
learn it's probably going to take us
another 20 30 or 40 or 50 years to learn
it but I think something we're going to
learn is that there was a lot of natural
friction that existed in life that made
a lot of the payoffs way more fulfilling
and as we've gotten better with tech
we've gotten really good at removing the
friction from [ __ ] everything but I
think at the end what what like oh like
um like everything so I'm sure you've
read books before right
like there is a feeling even for
fictional books I'm not just talking
synonym of a fictional book maybe people
here for like read at least like Harry
Potter right there is a feeling to like
turning the last page in a book and
closing it that will never be matched by
scrolling memes on Tick Tock or Reddit
for like 12 hours but it's so easy to
scroll for memes that like maybe let's
just do that let's do that all day every
day like if you look at your screen time
on your phone you'll like throw up like
four five six seven eight hours a day on
your screen staring at your phone
scrolling through memes and you'll
remember any of these there's like no
fulfilling experience there ever but um
the friction is like not there at all
like it's I just pick up my phone and I
push and I get a happy button over and
over and over again
um the idea behind like uh meeting
people even
like where do you meet most of your
friends and everything in life like
people wouldn't expect that like okay
well we choose our friends we do Choice
freedom and blah blah no no no no no no
it's in the areas that you're the most
restricted you meet a lot of friends and
dating partners I think in school well
you're forced to socialize with people
or in the work environment we are forced
to be around people or in these places
where like you're thrown together with
20 or 30 other kids and you have to like
socialize with them and usually that's
like an overwhelmingly positive thing 99
of people come out with at least one
friend or like friend groups or whatever
um
I mean without getting too controversial
did you follow like the Robin Hood
GameStop all that dude how do you feel
about that what you mean a group of
people just LARPing their way to
potential Financial ruin or loads of
chicken tendies
um okay cool okay I think we're on the
same page then yeah um okay because some
people really Champion that as like the
other little dog story but um I think
one thing that we learned we talk about
friction is uh without getting too
complicated in the finance thing but
there's this idea that you have apps now
that allow you to buy and sell stocks
for free
um and it's so cool and so gratifying
and it's gamified you download these
apps you can do it and now you get a lot
of these people that are buying and
selling stocks have no idea what they're
and they're losing all their money on it
and it's like maybe there should be like
a little fee attached to a trade so you
have to think at least a little bit
before you push that button to buy or
sell a stock
um it's not just it's not trading it's
gambling yeah of course yeah that's true
um but yeah I just I think it feels like
there are so many areas in life where
having that little bit of friction is
good you should work a little bit to do
something because it does something to
the human brain it gives you a more
satisfying fulfilling experience and
left to their own devices humans will
you know inject [ __ ] heroin into
their minds and push a button and stare
at something and do that for the rest of
their lives without anything like I
think we need to have we need to be
somewhat on Rails we need to yeah have
at least a little bit of friction in
life to make sure you're working for
some types of Rewards or else it's just
so poisonous to the mind the path of
least resistance is the one that you're
always going to be able to find does
this concept I learned about called the
region beta Paradox you heard of this
nope pretty cool uh imagine you have a
rule you always walk when you're
traveling a mile or less and you always
drive when you're going more than a mile
if you follow that rule you will
paradoxically travel two miles faster
than you travel one mile the important
Insight here is if if you only take
action when things cross a certain
threshold of Badness sometimes better
things can feel worse than worse things
look around and you find lots of people
stuck in region beta the guy who sticks
around it is just okay job instead of
ditching it for the chance for something
better the couple who should break up
but can't bring themselves to do it the
friend who refuses to get a new
apartment because their current one has
some black mold all of these people
would actually be better off if their
situations were worse because they'd
leave their jobs partners and apartments
and be glad they did their only regret
would be not leaving sooner and that
zone of comfortable complacency
Comfortably Numb scenario is where a lot
of people get stuck not with the
activation energy to kick out at the
bottom because it's terrible and not
ascended to the top of the highest
flourishing Heights that human
civilization could offer them gotcha
okay I didn't know that name but I know
this concept from the other end I want
to say there might be a name for
something called decision paralysis but
basically it's like if you could graph
like the discomfort or whatever in going
into a new situation it's always going
to get a little bit worse before it gets
better and getting over that initial bad
hump is really challenging for a lot of
people the way that I overcame this is
anytime I've got like kind of shitty
decisions
um that I have in front of me there's
one thing that's always going to be true
well I assume it's going to be true and
that's that time always moves forward
and so in one year three years or five
years you will get there you're going to
be 35 you're going to be 37 you're going
to be 39. you are going to be there and
given that you know that to be true
looking back on this moment what
decision would you have been happier
making and using that process there have
been times where I've been to make kind
of like decisions that are hard that are
not gonna be shitty for a while but it's
like I know that three years from now if
I look back and I continue this path I'm
gonna [ __ ] hate myself because I can
already look back one year it's like
[ __ ] why didn't that guy make that
decision you [ __ ] [ __ ] why would I
stick here and then in three years be
like [ __ ] like it feels really [ __ ] if
you think it feels really bad to sink
two years into something that sucks try
singing 10 years into it holy [ __ ] and
if you think 10 years is bad you might
be in a 10 year bet you might be 32
years old in a shitty relationship like
[ __ ] me I've wasted my whole 20s try
wasting your whole 30s and 40s okay
dating at 55 is a lot harder than dating
at 30 you know um there's always yeah
you've always got so much to be grateful
for you've always got like so much that
you can improve on but sometimes
there'll be little bumps that make it
hard to get over it um I think this is a
really well known phenomenon too another
another reminder of that is um there was
some military Colonel or somebody I
don't remember but I think that
um I feel like I watched this guy give
an inspirational speech and he said that
you should try to set your goal to do
like some really menial tasks like um I
think I think he said brush one tooth
like don't don't you don't have to go to
the bathroom to brush your teeth just
brush one tooth and the idea is that by
the time you get there if you do if you
nobody just brushes one tooth if you do
that you're going to do the rest right
or if you go to the gym it's like okay I
don't want to go into Mentor as a gym
I'm just going to the gym and do one
lift I'm gonna go and I'm gonna squat
I'm Gonna Leave well chances are if you
go when you do your one lift you're not
going to want to leave after 20 minutes
you're going to do the rest of your
workout because you're already there you
know but yeah I agree with what you're
saying that is a real phenomenon and you
have to learn a lot of little tricks to
get your mind over that little hump
because that little hump is
insignificant as it is can destroy your
entire [ __ ] life because you'll never
get over it and you'll be comfortable
um [ __ ] what is it [ __ ] there are Pink
Floyd lyrics or whatever before you know
it like your whole life is gone and
you're from Dark Side of the Moon but
yeah
um yeah that little bump can be really
damaging to a lot of people
beginning the momentum is super super
hard a really great question that I had
people ask during covid was look you've
got we don't know how long we're going
to be in lockdown we're going to be in
lockdown for four months say or six
months I ended up being a bit longer in
the UK what would have had to have
happened by the end of lockdown for you
to look back on lockdown and consider it
a success you have the entire world at
your feet yeah you can't travel and yeah
there's restrictions on your freedoms
and what what
but really you can do anything you want
you want to lose five pounds do you want
to start learning a new language or play
the piano or improve your relationship
with your kids what would have had to
have happened
over the next four months for you to
look back and consider it a success and
that
ends up giving you so much perspective
in an insanely Accurate Way do you look
back oh it's obvious what I want to have
happen I know what I want to have happen
over the next few months
and yet without the little tricks that
can push that inertia and just get it
out of the way people get stuck in zero
as opposed to in one yeah for sure yeah
life is is very easy right now so it's
in some ways it's scary yeah
can you explain to me what stochastic
terrorism is because I'm seeing this
term get thrown around on the internet a
lot and I don't know what it is used to
be really popular five years ago it's a
bit out of um out of date now I don't
think people use it as much maybe it's
coming back but stochastic terrorism is
basically the idea that like I'm going
to lead you to the assault rifle of the
school but I'm not gonna make you pull
the trigger it's basically like what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna provide all the
necessary circumstances and rhetoric for
you to feel like you need to take
violent action without me saying it so
uh have you ever heard of like the great
replacement
kind of so that might be an idea so
basically maybe I'll talk about like
okay listen there are brown people
they're coming to your country they're
raping your women they're taking over
they're becoming bigger voting blocks
and you're going to lose all of your
rights all of your freedoms and
eventually you're going to be a minority
your own country and you're going to be
subjugated to their rule
now I'm not going to take a way to do
about it but I'm going to make sure you
really understand that right and then so
when this type of rhetoric becomes very
pervasive like inevitably somebody's
gonna feel like they have to stand up
and take action because holy [ __ ]
because I mean obviously if you really
believe it's happening you probably
should take action and then the violence
that results from that people would say
like well that's a result of stochastic
terrorism maybe
um okay so laying all of the breadcrumbs
up into a point at which something can
flare up that's right yeah but also
having culpable deniability to be able
to stay away from it do you think that
is it everywhere at the moment or not I
think it's a very I think there are a
lot of things that are fun tools to use
to analyze what's going on in society
you just be very careful when you start
swinging out your moral Hammer about
condemnation because um like yeah like I
think that the concept of stochastic
terrorism is a good one and it's
something we should analyze but like
depending on how flexible you want to be
with it like everybody does it right
like you could argue that the um the
massive BLM riots in the United States
um were part of that was stochastic
terrorism that like saying that police
were all going to kill black people that
politicians don't care about you voting
doesn't matter capitalists hate you well
of course people are gonna go right and
destroy everything and steal [ __ ]
because you know why wouldn't you if
that's what you believe
um so yeah you just I think that it's
good to I like the concept because it's
good to view like well where does our
rhetorically people like if if somebody
in my audience let's say that I found
out right now that somebody in my
audience went and did a mass shooting
and he killed a bunch of women
um do I feel like I've said things that
lead people down that road because if so
I would want to change I don't want
people to feel that way I feel like I
have a responsibility to my audience
that I'm not giving them a message where
it feels like the only way out is you
know through violence or something
um so yeah I think it's a good concept
to know of and to be aware of
um but don't like get weird about like
calling people terrorists and [ __ ] and
go like crazy or whatever yeah it's the
terrorism part that I didn't quite
understand because terrorism is a very
specific type of
crime phenomenon that people engage in
and I I don't know I didn't
it didn't see it just seems like and
that might just be a lexical problem
right it might just have poor branding
but it didn't really seem to make so
much sense to me that being said the
unsaid things what it is that you're not
saying is often as powerful as what you
are saying and I suppose that this
speaks to that um vacuum that allows
speculation to fill it and then for
people to take action off the back of
the speculation yeah it's very relevant
to what we were talking about with like
the um manosphere stuff
um Jordan Peterson does this a lot but
we won't have to get into that but like
somebody will come away from like a lot
of red pill stuff and somebody maybe a
left linear person will look at them be
like you guys hate women like it feels
like you hate women and then the other
crowd will look at you like find me one
time in this entire video where we said
that we hated women and it's like well I
guess you're never seven it's like
that's right because we love women
it's like okay maybe you do but like if
you look at all of the messaging all of
the carousel comments all of the like
[ __ ] hoe comments all of the like
virgins are the only women worth
anything comments all of the women are
like the succubi that are looking for
provide what it feels like you hate when
but I guess you never really just say
yeah if that level of plausible
deniability and that inevitability to
where you're leading your audience that
I think like triggers the [ __ ] out of a
lot of people or at least it triggers me
sometimes yeah I heard Hassan say I have
hatred in my heart for this man was that
actually about you
probably we have a very uh is it sorted
the word length are very sorted history
I think why I would have considered both
of you guys are from the left I know
that there's distances that you can go
on the left but I would have thought
that you guys would have been that's a
whole other hour long it's a very long
history I didn't realize there was law
oh yeah it was we he kind of came from
my community
um a long time maybe three years ago
um there's a lot yeah there's a lot of
[ __ ] son yeah well I mean this is this
is one of the things that people often
talk about the fact that on the right
the way that some of the more bombastic
commentators can go about things it
makes it kind of obvious that this
person is disagreeing with this person
and there's infighting and so on and so
forth I think because of at least
publicly how a lot of the left wing is
presented at the moment the empathy the
kindness The Compassion the inclusion so
on and so forth uh it's kind of assumed
that everybody also gets on that that
included
Harmony but it seems like maybe not I
think there's something called the
bigotry of small differences where yes
you just you have distaste for the
people that are like you more than the
people that aren't like you yeah and I
think I actually kind of feel that too
now now that I've seen it firsthand
um like if I'm arguing with a
conservative person and Their audience
is like calling me like a [ __ ] a loser a
[ __ ] boy blah whatever like I don't
care like what like why the [ __ ] would I
care like sure okay but when I argue
with left-leaning people and their
audiences are all calling me like
transphobic and Ray racist and hateful
it's like no not at all what the [ __ ]
are you talking about like those insults
that come from crowds that are more
politically similar to me bother the
[ __ ] out of me because their attacks
against me are in my world are totally
[ __ ] untrue like I don't like [ __ ]
you like that's not even remotely true I
imagine it's probably similar for like
even like nanosphere guys if people want
like oh you hate women you guys are blah
blah blah blah whatever [ __ ] you like
what do you know you know whereas like
if you're getting attacked by another
manosphere guy and he's calling you like
oh well you're kind of a [ __ ] or like I
don't think you'll really be man enough
then you're like oh what the [ __ ] this
is my whole philosophy of course I am um
so yeah I think that the closer you're
ideologically to somebody the more
irritated you are like some of those
smaller differences whereas with really
huge differences you're like yeah we're
totally different like yeah what is it
yeah uh I suppose as well you would
presume that the people who were on a
different side to you would understand
the Nuance of your argument a lot less
whereas the people the people who do
have that same side you go look
the fear and the reason it might strike
a little bit closer to you is that maybe
there could be some veracity to what
they're saying I don't think that there
is but what if there is what if it is
the fact that they understand they've
read all the same books as me they
follow the same people as me and they've
come up with this particular conclusion
yeah no yeah I know what you mean yeah
because they're closer so it feels like
they're like if somebody makes a wildly
outlandished this is actually true of
all content creators not to reveal too
much of a secret but like if you go into
a Content creators like chat room or
Twitter whatever and you say like oh I
hate you because you're like you know
you're four feet tall and like okay
whatever I don't care but if somebody
goes into like I hate you because you
have very weird ears and that's
something that the person feels like
self-conscious about that insult is
going to hit a lot more it's like [ __ ]
is he right like are my ears kind of
weird you know like people will the
things that are more true the more true
an insult is the more kind of bothers
somebody and people on your side are
probably able to dig into something that
is like more like resembling to the
things that you care about or more
resembling of like your similar
ideologies yeah such that they'll get
under your skin more I think I was at a
cricket match a couple of years ago and
there was it was a very drinky one day
Affair one of the players that was on
the pitch who was black had recently had
his wife cheat on him with some other
Cricket play that wasn't on the pitch at
the same time the crowd after they'd had
quite a few beers and it was a little
bit later in the day started doing a
chant about this guy's wife and about
way she was and whatever it's like a
mean [ __ ] I mean chant around him
it made me really reflect on the fact
that had they have decided to make a
chant about his skin color every single
person would have been called out on
social media arrests would have been
attempted so on and so forth but the
Precision targeted weapons grade
pharmaceutical chant about something
very specific that was not an immutable
truth of himself that he basically
didn't get to choose but was a byproduct
of his lifestyle
that was somehow permitted yeah that
blew my mind the difference between
those two things and it seems like it
kind of throws into interesting light
what we mean by freedom of speech and
things that are protected and things
that aren't because sometimes the region
beta right sometimes worse things can
feel better than better things or at
least worse in the eyes of the law yeah
yeah absolutely for sure yeah and I'm
sure there are some people where you can
say some things about them that like
everybody look like a racial slur or
sexist slur or something like that
you're like that's horrible but like if
you can dig in really deep on other
insults and be like oh well that's kind
of mean or whatever but it's like you
know not pretty good yeah exactly yeah
for sure what would you do if you were a
if you were trying to advise the left on
how to re-engage with men online what
what needs to be dispensed with or what
would be the the place that you can
begin at because you're right it is very
much dominated by people that have more
conservative Traditional Values but if
you want to have a healthy debate you
need to have people from all sides well
what are some ideas that you've got
about how to engage more effectively
um this is It's really cringy because
everybody says this but I guess I'll
throw my hat into the ring and say it as
well
um you have to be willing to engage with
truthful things once you've kind of let
the truth take a backseat to your
political ideology you've like
compromised your ability to communicate
with anybody so as soon as you've gotten
to a world where it's like oh well men
and women like I've had huge arguments
with people where they've told me that
like men and women are roughly the same
strength as each other except sometimes
cultural differences make it a little
bit different and when you're starting
to have arguments like that nobody's
going to listen to anything you're
saying because it's clearly you want men
and women to be equal so much that
you're willing to sacrifice like true
observations for things that now you're
just you're in another world yeah you're
like your epistemic statements your your
ideas about like Gathering knowledge and
Truth in the world that can't take a
back seat to what you feel is right
um that's that's yeah that's not good
and conservatives do it too sometimes to
some extent I won't say it's just people
in love but people on the left are
especially egregious with it right now
when it comes to analyzing things
relating to like men and women or trans
people or some other types of social
issues as well you know you have to be
willing to start and that's usually
that's how I usually build Bridges with
people on the right is I'll start with
like a true observation like if you come
at me and you're like well I think that
black people do actually commit a lot
more crime in the US than white people
like yeah they do I'll agree with you um
that's an important part of my analysis
right well why do they commit more crime
that's like the important question to
ask not trying to fight well if we
massage the stats enough I can actually
show you like the crime is actually the
same if I control for age if I control
for demographic if I control for where
they live in the city if I control for
this and then it's like oh it's the
exact same I was like yeah well if you
control for enough [ __ ] things you
can make everything the same as another
thing you know
um but uh yeah I think that that's like
my big that would be my big you guys
like be willing to make true bold
observations and then work from there
and that yeah I mean I mean [ __ ] like we
have all like the sociologists and the
anthropologists and I shouldn't have
left anyway that should be your job
regardless is to make those hard strong
observations then build from there it
surprises me given the fact that there
would be a market for a left-leaning
commentator who wants to speak to men
about personal development and dating
and stuff like that the online content
creation world is a pretty good market
for allowing uh gaps and unsatisfied
audiences to be fed because as soon as
somebody starts to find it they get
audience captured and start to go down
that rabbit hole is it a fear of being
sort of lambasted as a whatever phobosed
from the left that is stopping creators
from going and doing that at the moment
do you think yeah I mean like there's
kind of there's always like an
ideological Purity that's enforced
really by everybody on the internet not
an ideological an ideological Purity and
an ideological rigidity such that if You
Buck any one of some statement that
you're supposed to be on board with
people with you as literally the
opposite side like there's a lot of
people that accuse me being like a
far-right Creator or fascist or a Nazi
adjacent I've gotten a lot because I
don't like toe the line on every single
level anything even though I'm more
Progressive than probably 95 of people
on the planet
um or 99 of people on the planet like 95
people like the Western World so
um yeah I mean it's I I can see the fear
there wanting to stay with your tribe
and not be like an outcast and the
sacred cow if you decide to go for one
of them that's you that's game over
um the sacred cow if you decide to go
for one of them like one of these one of
the Sacred cows like declaring that
gender differences are actually real
declaring that men and women aren't the
same oh yeah you get yeah depending on
which idea you hit on yeah you can get a
lot of trouble for that one yeah for
sure
Destiny ladies and gentlemen if people
want to check out the stuff that you do
online where should they go on
youtube.com Destiny on instagram.com
Destiny and I've got a friend on Twitter
called necro liberalism but uh I'm
banned on Twitter so I'm not allowed to
have accounts there but yeah dude I
appreciate you thank you yeah thanks a
lot what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]